good evening i want to start tonight
with an image that i can't get out of my
head it's this pair of green converse
sneakers a hand-drawn
heart on the right toe
they belonged to mai tai rodriguez a
nine-year-old girl who was gunned down
in the uvalde school massacre
18 other children and two teachers were
killed alongside her well last night the
actor matthew mcconaughey who was born
in nevalde spoke at the white house and
gave a speech that i believe will be a
seminal moment in america's gun violence
debate
he asked his wife camilla to bring those
shoes to the briefing room
camilla's got these shoes can you show
these shoes please
wear these every day
green converse with a heart on the right
toe
this is the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about
that i have a 10 year old daughter she
wears sneakers she loves to draw i can't
even begin to comprehend the scale of a
horror like this nobody should it's not
normal it's not okay
i don't think it's been a more powerful
or harrowing speech at the white house
briefing room maybe ever
and it was about so much more than just
raw emotion
mcconaughey wasn't there to take sides
or to lecture responsible gun owners to
disarm or to preach from a lofty
hollywood platform about the ignorance
of one side or the other he didn't take
sides
he even spoke about valde being the
place where he'd learned to be a
responsible gun owner himself
now this was an appeal to all americans
whatever their views about guns we heard
from we heard from so many people right
families of the deceased mothers fathers
sisters brothers texas rangers hunters
border patrol and responsible gun owners
who won't give up their second amendment
right to bear arms and you know what
they all
said we want secure and safe schools and
we want gun laws that won't make it so
easy for the bad guys to get these damn
guns well pierce let me just say
something to you because i've always
wanted to say it to you let me just say
it
i really appreciate the stance you took
on gun control when you were in america
and had your show i thought it was
incredibly brave you were on late night
television and you just said what you
had to say so i've always wanted to say
this to you other things i want to say
to you but that's what i definitely want
to say well thank you i mean here's what
i would say back to that thank you for
saying that but
when i watched mcconaughey yesterday i
wished actually i borrowed more of his
approach no no no no no no you did the
right thing because you were in a
country where you're a foreigner okay
let's let's and and you never heard that
you never hit who you were when you had
yours nobody's not down to a brit to
tell americans yeah exactly so you you
you hit that you were close to the wind
anyway and sang it so you did it
perfectly didn't you feel when
mcconaughey the weight the way he didn't
set out to demonize gun owners or even
call for gunboats
what he said was these are the things we
can do with surely we can all agree well
let's take on board the fact that he's
an incredibly good actor yeah so he
knows how to control a room he knows how
to work a room he's a gun owner so he's
not going to sit there and say don't
have any guns like me that may be more
powerful to me exactly so he he paced
himself
he gave the killer blow but it's not
going to make any difference right and
that's well that's what haralda said
it's incredible not no different i i
don't know i hope it does something i
just wanted to to play you a message
actually because you've become extra
famous in the uk because our champion
world heavyweight boxing hero tyson fury
loves to sing american pie when he wins
and we have a message for you from the
great man
hey tyson fury here this is a special
message to don mclean
i hear you on the pace morgan show
tonight don
absolutely smash it brother um i loved
our rendition of american pie it was
absolutely fantastic
um high pace hope you're having a good
time guys don't do anything i wouldn't
and smash it good luck guys all the best
god bless you
how cool is that well you know i was i
was i was going to tell tyson i love to
meet him someday i love him he is what
boxing has needed um he is a lovable
champion and he's a great champion and i
wanted to tell him
that um whenever i get in trouble now
i'm going to say that i have him as my
best friend
and i'm going to warn anybody who's
trying to mess with me that i have him
on speed dial you know what i mean
and and i wanted to say back to him that
if he has any trouble from like paul
simon or someone like that that i'll
handle that i can i can take paul simon
i want to play you a clip and then come
for your reaction
i'm about to go look the president in
the eye
and what i'd like to know no
it's where everyone stands on this thing
now
very simply
is he there or is he not in there
i gotta say i thought you came out of
that brilliantly and i don't know you
but if if i was you i would have loved
all that
well uh i remember when uh
gandalfini wrote me a note uh and said
you know you probably don't like the way
i played this role uh but i really
admire you so i called him up i met him
at some events uh and uh he said uh he
said you know he said i i i hope uh i
hope you like the way i played it i said
look i said it's a movie i'm glad they
picked an italian to play in italian
that that made me feel good uh and he
came back and he said you know he said
they made me use a lot of four-letter
words and i said well you know that's
the one thing you got right
[Laughter]
it's actually a great film i think the
the the best thing imaginable when
someone makes a big movie like that is
that it's good and i think not only was
it good but you had this amazing actor
playing you and as i say i thought you
came out as badass